bitcoin is a digital currency apparently
invented by a Japanese software
mastermind a Bitcoin is just a piece of
data a string of information the whole
Bitcoin system works through a
peer-to-peer computer network which
means that when you're running Bitcoin
software on your computer you're
connected to all the other computers in
the network
every time you buy bitcoins or use them
to buy something the whole network gets
updated with that information these
transaction records eventually formed
blocks long chains of data that
computers can hack or solve the process
of solving these blocks creates more
bitcoins and is called mining so the
more Bitcoin transactions there are the
more blocks that are created more blocks
means more chances for computers to mine
bitcoins the system is kind of
self-reinforcing genies but it's also
self limiting blocks actually become
harder and harder to mine over time so
that there can only ever be 21 million
bitcoins total so far there are 12
million and Counting